the thumbnail you just clicked on May
look like clickbait but it's actually a
legitimate part of this video in which
we will be exploring what Luffy's
Awakening and possible gear 5 will look
like and why the gomogonomi might
already have woken up hi my name is Manu
I'm not a rubber man but according to my
doctor I have a serious caffeine
addiction and for the past two weeks
I've become obsessed with learning the
secret behind devil fruits and finding
out Luffy's awakened form because how
the hell did law and kids do it before
him in the last video I made my case
that there are actual devils in Devil
fruits whose Soul merge with that of the
user not only granting them their powers
but even inheriting the will of past
users of the fruit
I also explained all the fundamentals
about how devil fruits in general as
well as each of their individual
categories work so I strongly recommend
you check that one out right after this
as they go hand in hand the first thing
I want to discuss is whether Luffy
actually needs an Awakening in the first
place my short answer is yes duh the
more badass the better but I'm aware
that many people actually don't feel
that way and I guess you could fairly
enough argue that Luffy didn't need to
rely on his own Awakening to take down
the likes of doflamingo katakuri or the
guards in impel down
foreign
not only has future side hockey but
Advanced Armament and even Advanced
conquerors hockey on a top level as well
instead of relying only on his fruit
he's combining it with his hockey as no
other character in the story has done so
far and in the end seeing him being
creative with his fruit is much much
more important to me than unlocking new
powers I think but I think if you argue
like this you probably have
misunderstood what Awakening truly is
now Awakening a fruit doesn't mean
flipping on a switch and automatically
getting a bunch of new powers flowing in
minor spoiler alert as loss and kids
Awakening shows us it seems to be much
more of a process that requires a lot of
energy and then increasingly gives the
user additional reach and Effectiveness
on their powers allowing them to break
the rules a little bit but the main
prerequisite for awakening is true
Mastery over one's devil fruit something
that only very few people are able to do
and I think suggesting that Luffy hasn't
or maybe never will truly Master the
gomogomanomi is something that I just
can't ever see happening like ever ever
ever ever ever ever
kaido might be the physically strongest
enemy he will have to face in battle but
I think we all agree that for the coming
arcs things won't get easier but harder
for Luffy facing a kainu Blackbeard and
ultimately taking down the world
government itself all of it will require
Luffy to maximize his potential and I
hope you agree that Awakening his devil
fruit will be an essential part of that
so how close is Luffy to reaching this
level are we talking juano or elbaf or
left tail well I would say let's look at
all the factors that should or could
determine how much more Luffy needs now
the first factor in mastering anything
is age and it's not exactly in Luffy's
favor people tend to forget that our
meat-eating hero is not even legally
allowed to drink alcohol in Japan or the
US well Germany is different there you
can start drinking at 16 uh where was I
oh yeah Luffy is extremely young while
though Flamingo and katakuri are 41 and
48 years old respectively more than
twice his own age they had a lot of time
to figure out their powers and use them
on countless enemies and in many
different situations however we also
know that Luffy just like law and
probably kids have had their devil
fruits from when they were kids
basically doing nothing but honing their
skills for years
and they are the leaders of the worst
generation for a reason all three of
them and Luffy especially are fighting
prodigies the next factor is the
structure of the story if Luffy should
awaken it's gonna be soon there is a lot
of Prophecy around opening wano and the
man that Roger was waiting for and so
the year of the prophets if you want to
call it that is right now 20 years later
and even though you might say that's not
a fair argument that doesn't change the
fact that it's true
now hockey and devil fruits are somewhat
related and even comparable in the story
there are three types each with its own
subcategories and advanced versions and
one of the most important lessons for
unlocking one's haki according to
Rayleigh is this
so one of the same thing is true for
awakening just like Advanced haki can
only bloom in the heat of the hardest
battles Awakening one's devil fruit
might also be bound to fighting strong
opponents on the grand line over and
over just what Luffy has been doing his
hockey and devil fruit powers are
intricately interwoven with each other
and in terms of Mastery of his devil
fruit well this was actually really
fascinating to think about Luffy is a
quite special case after all he's a
paramecia user yes but unlike dophier
magillan who produced their substance or
missed the one who transforms his entire
body into one Luffy is 100
organically made out of rubber as we can
see in this scene here he is not doing
anything to turn into it
in fact it's the other way around it
took Luffy years of training with Ace
and Sabo to get basic control over his
new body before he could even think
about using it for combat he has to make
an active effort to force his body into
shape which is basically the same as for
logia users the only difference being
that they embody some sort of energy
thus the extra category of special
paramecia that borders very very close
to the logia category so the fact that
Luffy can run around without randomly
stretching all the time is already a big
feat in itself for example when he picks
up usop on water 7 his arm stretches but
his fingers stay normal otherwise that
might have ended pretty badly for us up
there
do it
in his base form Luffy uses his muscle
power to stretch in gear second he
expands on this by using his rubber body
to pump blood and thus increase his
power and speed and pumping your own
blood faster seems like a pretty
fantastic control over his fruit to me
the third is the same using the rubber
properties of his bones to expand his
entire body stretching and then forcing
it into a gigantic shape and with gear
fourth it really gets interesting
because here he uses the internal
expansion of his third gear but limits
it with hockey compressing his body
which allows him to use the properties
of this hardened rubber as a result his
movements are so fast that the air has
no time to go anywhere allowing him to
fly while he can even charge up his
punches releasing them with even more
power and speeds
[Music]
just imagine taking a really hard and
thick spring and compressing it flat
before unleashing it that's Luffy's
entire body in gear fourth so while he
does use hockey as a crutch here he is
able to control his powers even more
harshly and precisely with this
technique the point I'm trying to make
here is that Luffy has already taking
his rabba body to the extreme could you
creatively come up with a completely
different use of his power probably but
the way he Masters his body and uses it
freely is pretty pretty masterful in my
books at least so based on this I would
argue that Luffy has actually already
been ready for his Awakening during the
time skips similar to kit and law I
think the only difference here is that
Luffy was not really aware that devil
fruit Awakening was even a thing until
though Flamingo told him about it but
maybe even more importantly he has been
really focused on hockey stating the
obvious Rayleigh has no devil fruit he
was a Pure Hockey Mentor for Luffy
because without advanced haki you can't
even touch the big guns in the New World
and so I'm pretty sure that Luffy's
Awakening will come to him pretty
swiftly should he ever feel like his
hockey had reached its limits so let's
say it happens in the fight against
kaido who might have his own Awakening
or even a bit later but what will
Luffy's Awakening actually look like for
logia users we suspect that they can
turn the Mad around them into their
respective elements for Zone fruits it
means a larger monster-like version of
themselves that has increased stats
across the board
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
but since Luffy doesn't do us the luxury
of fitting smoothly into one of these
two categories there are a lot of
possibilities so in the end I decided to
look at this question in terms of three
criteria internal versus external likely
versus unlikely and whether or not I
like it or not this is my video after
all but please let me know what you
think let's start with internal this
would mean that instead of affecting his
surroundings like doflamingo Luffy's
fruit would actually enhance his ability
inside his body loss Awakening for
example is an enhancement of his current
abilities as well and you could also
argue that unlike doflamingo who only
produces his string Luffy is actually
made out of rubber that's his power so
considering that his Awakening would
only affect himself is not really all
that unlikely to imagine and also if
gear 5 really was connected to Awakening
I think it would mostly make sense for
an internal one the first idea here is
basically Luffy being able to go into
overdrive with his Awakening Luffy gains
complete control over his body he's now
freely able to mix and switch between
gears whenever he pleases the result
might look like a much Slimmer version
of gear 4th expanding his muscles
pumping blood while compressing
everything much much more drastically
this form would give him not only
ridiculous speed and strength but also
the variety that gear forth lacked
[Music]
foreign
basically this is all gear 4 variations
at once I think it's pretty easy to see
something like this happening but I
think it would be a bit of a waste for
such an important update so rated 4 out
of 10. the next internal Awakening
theory is vulcanization and that doesn't
only sound pretty cool it is
vulcanization means that through heat
rubber is made smaller harder and way
way more durable when you think about it
this fits Luffy's Fire theme very very
nicely that could be a great Catalyst
for that and in return might allow him
to tolerate heat and fire way better
oh
similar to overdrive Luffy would get a
boost to all his stats but more
importantly it might allow him to form
shapes with his body and Harden them so
Luffy could actually form weapons and
shapes with his body similar to Mr one I
think this idea is a lot more Niche than
the last but I like it a lot more so I
give it a solid 7 out of 10. last for
the internal Awakening options I have a
really cool one you know how Luffy can
make a body part Giant in gear third
well what if his Awakening enhances his
abilities in a way that allow Luffy's
entire body to stretch like this giving
him a true giant form first of all I
love that idea just aesthetically but
there is more to it you might remember
from my emo video that there already is
a connection between Luffy and Giants
ORS was basically a giant with Luffy's
personality trying to use his abilities
and then there is the really big straw
hat on marijuana
foreign
that it's Joy Boys Luffy could literally
wear that big straw hat if he had a
giant form heck who knows maybe there's
even something on love tail that
requires a giant to work it remember the
world government and also kaido are
trying to create Giants at any cost the
only thing that is preventing them from
being successful right now is that they
are not yet subscribed to my channel for
Next Generation anime contents so do I
think this is likely probably not but if
it's true oh boy I would be on board for
the right nine out of ten okay so now
let's talk about external Awakening
options external meaning pretty much
exactly how doflamingo described it the
power of the fruit starts affecting the
world around the user though Flamingo
was able to turn things around him into
string and kid is able to magnetize
other objects not sure if magnetized is
the scientifically correct term you
though the biggest argument for this
oven in internal Awakening is katakuri I
think his abilities are the closest to
Luffy in the entire story and his
Awakening is clearly portrayed as
turning the things around him into Mochi
amongst other things
[Music]
so Theory number one Luffy's Awakening
turns the world into a bouncy castle
probability not zero popularity thanks I
hate it 0 out of ten next the way more
tolerable version of this is that Luffy
can turn things around him into rubber
but in a unique and more creative way so
instead of turning his hand into a sword
how about turning a house into another
Luffy basically creating clones or
imagine him springing arms and legs out
of the ground and having his Enemy
barraged by an all-round Gatling gun I
do like this a lot more than bouncy
castle but the problem is that this
would basically be a Naruto X Robin love
child's Shadow clone fist attack that
doesn't really matter against a real
opponent
so I rate this as very possible but I'm
not the biggest fan so I don't know four
out of 10. so for the last one I have a
super crazy one for you if your favorite
wasn't in this by the way let me know
what it is the most out there crazy
external Awakening theory for the
gomugomonomi have come across is that
Luffy as a rubber man is not only gonna
be able to stretch his body or even
matter itself the idea is that Luffy
will be able to literally stretch time
and space to distort the entire world
around him this would truly be a game
changer and put him on an entirely new
level I think the possibility of this is
like one percent but I love it 10 out of
10 and now make sure to watch the other
devil fruit video here what are you
doing go watch it we're still doing here
get the hell out of here